you
[Music]
when I was a kid I used to watch a lot
of science fiction and of course
time-travel is one of the main plots
that dominates science fiction but I
said to myself you know if I pursue this
path of simply reading science fiction
I'll eventually just start to mouth all
these words these buzz words from
science fiction and be clueless
absolutely clueless about whether or not
any of these things can actually happen
well that's when I said to myself you
know I have to sit down and get serious
if I'm really serious about learning
about the frontiers of science and when
it meets science fiction I'm gonna have
to hit the books I'm gonna have to pay
my dues I'm gonna have to learn
theoretical physics I'm gonna have to
learn as much mathematics as I possibly
can to understand why Einstein could not
complete his unified field theory well
today I can read that book I can read
from Einstein's unified field theory the
theory that may one day answer these
questions about higher dimensions about
time travel about starships and
hyperdrive I can read that book now and
I realized that all the dead ends that
he was hitting I can see where he
stopped where certain avenues were
promising but he simply couldn't take it
any farther and the reason why is
because the nuclear force was not known
till the 1970s yeah and yet he was
working on the unified field theory
starting in the 1920s this was an
impossible task he was putting together
a jigsaw puzzle with one of the big
pieces missing and that big piece was
the nuclear force and so Einstein
understood the electromagnetic force he
of course pioneered the gravitational
force but he did not understand the
nuclear force well today we have a very
good grasp of the nuclear force the
nuclear forces are mediated by quarks
and gluons subatomic particles that we
physicists have to memorize but how many
subatomic particles are there hundreds
perhaps thousands of subatomic particles
with bizarre Greek sounding names in the
1950s J robert Oppenheimer
the father of the atomic bomb was so
frustrated that we began to find all
these this zoo of subatomic particles
that he made the announcement and that
is the Nobel Prize should go to the
physicist who does not discover a new
particle this year well today to get
your PhD you have to memorize the names
of all these goddamn subatomic particles
that's what I had to do but I would hope
that in the future young students in
theoretical physics instead of
memorizing all these Greek sounding
names would simply say string theory and
they would get their PhD string theory
says that all the notes on a vibrating
string correspond to a particle that an
electron is actually a rubber band a
very tiny rubber band but if you twang
this rubber band and the rubber band
vibrates at a different frequency it
turns into a quark and you twang it
again turns into a neutrino so how many
musical notes are there an infinite how
many musical notes are there on a string
an infinite number and that may explain
why we have so many subatomic particles
they're nothing but musical notes so
physics is nothing but the laws of
harmonies on a string chemistry is
nothing but the melodies you can play on
vibrating strings and the mind of God
the mind of God that Einstein worked on
for the last thirty years of his life
the mind of God would be cosmic music
cosmic music resonating through eleven
dimensional hyperspace you see our
universe is a symphony it's a symphony
of vibrating strings and possibly
membranes but when it was born it was
born as a perfect entity in eleven
dimensional hyperspace that may
eventually give us quote a theory of
everything so people come up to me and
say professor if this is a theory of
everything what's in it for me what's in
it for numero uno why should I care well
let me tell you why you should care
about a theory of everything when
Isaac Newton worked out a theory of
gravity he also worked out a mechanic's
how forces guide the motions of objects
including steam engines with steam
engines came the Industrial Revolution
so in some sense the work of Isaac
Newton helped to revolutionize society
with machines that could be understood
using Newton's laws of mechanics steam
engines that could then create
locomotives that could industrialize
America within a hundred and fifty years
and then in the 1800's we had the
pioneering work of Maxwell Faraday
leading up to the work of Edison that
gave us the electromagnetic force so the
unraveling of the second great force the
electromagnetic force gave us the
electric and computer and information
revolution of today your iPod the
internet GPS lasers computers microchips
all of that coming from the work of
scientists who unravel the second great
force the electromagnetic force the
third in the fourth forces are the
nuclear forces they make the stars shine
Einstein's famous equation e equals MC
squared unravels the secret of the stars
that a little bit of M matter can create
fabulous amounts of cosmic energy e the
nuclear force energizes the Stars is
responsible for the creation of the
earth and may one day energize our
machines with fusion reactors now we are
on the verge of the unification of all
forces all four fundamental forces
perhaps unified into an equation one
inch long that's the dream now
are we gonna get better cable television
this way are we gonna get better color
reception this way not immediately but
this theory the theory of everything
will answer the key questions is time
travel possible can you drill a hole
through space and time how was the
universe born and what happened before
Genesis itself string theory may answer
all these questions
for example time travel Isaac Newton
said the time and arrow once you fire it
it speeds uniformly throughout space and
time one second on the earth is one
second on Mars is one second throughout
the universe
Einstein comes along and says not so
fast not so fast time is a river the
river of time meanders its way
throughout the universe speeding up and
slowing down and we measure that every
day with our GPS systems with our own
Stein's theory of relativity you could
not have a DPS system that can locate
your position to within about ten feet
or so so the new wrinkle in all this is
that we believe that the river of time
has whirlpools whirlpools in the river
of time the river of time a fork into
two rivers and this may enter many of
the paradoxes of time travel what
happens if you go backwards in time and
shoot your parents before you're born
how can you be born if your parents were
just killed by you by going backwards in
time if time Forks into two rivers then
parallel universes emerge and that's how
we can resolve all the time travel
paradoxes but then people ask the
question professor this is all fine and
good but when can I have my own personal
time machine to visit the dinosaurs well
there's a problem there's always a catch
and the catch is the energy positive and
negative necessary to open gateways
through space and time is not for us if
time travel is possible then the fuel
the energy necessary to open up gateways
to create pretzels in the river of space
and time is fabulous you're talking
about the energy of a black hole the
energy of a supernova energy far beyond
anything that we can harness today but
perhaps who knows aliens from outer
space millions of years ahead of us
perhaps our descendants may be able to
wrap time into a pretzel
so one day if somebody knocks on your
door and claims to be your
great-great-great-great
great-great-great granddaughter don't
slam the door